let's go next to the caller from the
three one three area code who's calling
today from from three one three hey
David
my name is Sam I've been watching you
for a while now my my younger brother
kind of turned me on to your program
great and the thing I'm one day kind of
talk about today is the strategy for
impeachment that Democrats are kind of
trying to pitch right now they I watched
the video with I can't remember his name
now it's failing me
what's his face that he did the speech
on Clinton from the 90s eunji when the
office yeah I Lindsey Graham X's name
just the hypocrisy of you know the
entire GOP in the right wing how how do
people combat that I actually
unfortunately don't think there really
is any good way to combat the hypocrisy
and double standards from the GOP
because they've made it clear that they
don't care and you know we should have
known this all along and many of us did
because they've always been hypocrites
on the issue of the debt and the deficit
and they're equally hypocrites on all of
these other issues and I think we should
just forget about you know anybody
waiting around for Republicans to have
an awakening and saying hey wait a
second we said one thing when it was
Clinton and now we're saying something
else when it's Trump that's bad and we
should start B it's not gonna happen
it's just not gonna happen so I think
that we need to completely forget about
the idea of convincing Republicans to
say we should really be more consistent
morally and ethically we've just got to
remove the guy by voting them out in
November of 2020 I think that's the
fastest path forward now that doesn't
mean listen there's the you're talking
about the strategy behind impeachment
and that's perfectly fine to talk about
and I've been talking about it the other
side of it is just Congress has a duty
to act in a particular way when there's
evidence that certain things have taken
place and there's a growing case that
the Moller report is evidence that this
is a president who should be censured if
not impeached and
that's the case they just need to do it
putting strategy aside and they're kind
of two different issues but forget about
waiting around for Republicans to see
the light on on intellectual consistency
because it's not gonna happen I mean
it's just there's no way you're going to
get that to happen they're just gonna
keep pandering to their base of course
of course listen when they say we've got
to reduce the debt we've got to start
cutting the Deaf that the deficits got
to be reduced and we've got to start
paying off the debt because it's just
bad and it's destroying the economy and
then george w bush comes in and explodes
the deficit and then Donald Trump comes
in and explodes the gosset and when you
call them out about it they either say
what you're seeing and hearing isn't
really happening or they say yeah but we
need that for national security or
whatever I mean it's it's a joke you're
not gonna talk sense into them yeah
hundred percent agree I do contract work
and I Drive about a thousand plus miles
a week yeah different job price because
I try to talk politics with as many
people as I can in the most friendly way
possible and something that a lot of
people agree on is hey we spend a crap
ton of money on our military but now our
current administration is trying to cut
funding for you know the the Special
Olympics to save 13 million dollars and
in the same breath you've got you know
Donald Trump spending hundreds of
millions on all of his little golf
outings at his own resort yeah like the
emoluments clause you can just Chuck
that race the garbage if it's our guy
but if it's their guy you know Obama
went on vacation to Martha's Vineyard oh
no the country's gonna fall apart right
now it's just you know the the
disconnect that people have it's just
kind of astounding to me it isn't the
one bit of good news is it doesn't
matter how much they ignore their own
double standards and hypocrisy we can
vote them out in November of 2020 and
that's just what we've got to do let's
not forget that oh yeah yeah and that's
why I try to talk to as many people as I
can about the issue that matters like
the things that affect their lives
because that's where I'm trying to get
people to start thinking clearly like
hey you know you've got the actions of
one group that are trying to do their
best to make life more enjoy
and livable for the American people and
then you've got another group that only
cares about tax breaks for the rich and
their own very narrow set of talking
points to keep their base happiness yep
and then what a question I find it's a
useful one to ask is what would what
could Trump do that would get you to not
vote for him and you will see that a lot
of people can't actually say anything
which means they're not really
evaluating anything it's a cult of
personality it's a decision that's not
not based in fact
all right Sam great to hear from you
really appreciate the call and hope to
hear from you again we will go to a
break and be back with audience
questions right after this thanks to
everybody who called in today